كلفتني يا نور وراح نجرب كمان شوي ندخل
على بس انا جربت ما بياخد ما بيطلب مني اي
معلومات لا عمري ولا وزني ولا شو التارجت
يعني الوزن اللي انا بطمح اني اوصل له ولا
اشي بس طلبت منه انه يعطيني حميه هلا رح
نجرب وبلش يكتب طيب هلا انتم بتعملوا فحص
سريري عاده تاخدوا معلومات وافيه عن الشخص
الامراض الموجوده بتعملوا فحوصات معينه
بتعرفوا شو المشكله راويه انه ممكن فيه
باوقات انه يسالني بتعاني من امراض معينه
المشكله انه الشخص نفسه ممكن ما يكون بعرف
انه بيعاني من مرض معين ولكن من خلال
التشخيص الطبي والتغذوي انا كخصائيه تغذيه
ممكن اميز انه هذا الشخص من خلال واعراض
معينه انه هو بيكون بعاني من اعراض معينه
ولكن تشارجي بتصير يمكن ما يميز هذا الشيء
فيعطيني حمله غذائيه مش مناسبه لالي غير
راويه مثل ما هلا انت ذكرتي الف حص
السريري احنا عندنا بعيادات التغذيه في
عنا جهاز لفحص مكونات الجسم بعرف من
خلالها نسبه الدهون بعرف من خلاله وين
الدهون متركزه فمثلا لو كانت الدهون
متركزه عند منطقه البطن انا رح اعطي حميه
غذائيه بناء على الفحص مكونات هذه طيب خلي
تجربه انا كتبت له هل ممكن ان تعطيني حميه
غذائيه مناسبه طيب
[ضحك]
تخلصين هل
وانا عادي لازم انوه لموضوع احنا ما بنعطي
حميه غذائيه نعطيها زي ما راويه بناء على
طول على العمر على الوزن وعلى الحاله
الصحيه اوكي خليني اقول لكم شو كتب لمعرفه
مناسبه لك يمكنك اخذ بعض العوامل في
الاعتبار الهدف الغذائي الحاله الصحيه
تفضيلاتك انت والنشاط البدني
يا جماعه لانه الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن
يعطيكم
حميه غذائيه ولكنها ليست مفصله لكم هي
بشكل عام جدا وعمومك الحلو في هذه التجربه
نروي قرات من غير نظاره طيب شكرا
جزيلا يعطيك العافيه
الاختصاصيه التغذيه نور جهات شكرا جزيلا
لك شكرا يا نور
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات